I think someone who makes $80,000 a year
being a blogger about basketball is like
being the 12th man on a team you made it
to the league but you're not LeBron
you're one of the best basketball
players in the world but nobody knows
who you are kind of thing like there's
no shame as a matter of fact the the
practicality of making $80,000 a year
being a blogger about basketball because
you love it versus making 109 thousand a
year as a lawyer is a great arbitrage
for a lot of people it's the unlocking
happiness like is your life better
making one hundred nine thousand dollars
here being a lawyer versus making
$80,000 a year being a full-time
basketball content provider you know I
don't know people's situations you may
have loans you may have this but if you
can afford it I promise you you're going
to be way happier doing the stuff that
you want to be doing and those are
choices everybody has to make for
themselves but when I say not
everybody's gonna be LeBron I mean not
everybody's gonna be Mark Zuckerberg and
Steve Jobs and I'm here
that's right got it or within their
hobby and their job and making their
career their hobby that's right they
they can be the seventeenth night
there's a level of practicality that's
different for everyone predicated on how
fancy they want to be like where's your
happiness and where's the things you
want that you need money for where's
that Mendoza line there's a lot of
people for example right now we're
watching this who are doing well and
making $200,000 a year but if they made
140 they'd be much happier got it they
start working the machine takes over
that business eats them up like a lot of
people think that happens to me when I
don't understand me they don't get it I
already won I've won I'm getting to play
the game that I want to play like it's
not like I don't need to make more it's
not like you need to make more I need to
make more because it means that I'm
succeeding in the game that I'm playing
and that hearing pain that comes in of
course I'm ultimately patient I've only
won t Rock this games Vig I already won
I figured myself out I know what makes
me happy nothing in the world makes me
happier than being able to know and by
the way this is for everybody everybody
is the happiest when they get to do what
they want to be doing when you get to do
what you wanted
you've won that is the seductive nature
of entrepreneurship because you have
control there's no boss
but the company can become your boss
there's over extending yourself and
paying for your lifestyle can become
your boss not paying attention to what
makes you happy anymore can become your
boss and that's why I try to stay
grounded in that stuff like when people
don't know me and they video goes viral
and I call this guy's just going to be
miserable and he's because you'll just
want to make money you know me you don't
know move like there's plenty of people
that are miserable that have that are
home all day like misery doesn't come in
the way you want to judge it misery
comes in the way that it is for that
actual person and for me the time I get
to spend with my family and then the
fact that I get to spend a lot of time
playing the game that I want to play is
ultimate happiness I would suffocate and
die if I work 9:00 to 6:00
it wouldn't be happy well you know sorry
that's not politically correct it's it's
selfish like I want to work that 6:00 to
9:00 that so many of you go out to
dinner with friends or watch shows or
play volleyball or a part of it that's
what I'm doing it's just three more
hours of work I like my meeting is your
card club my meeting is your book club
my meeting is your pool table night my
meeting is your dart team my meeting is
you're going to the shore and surfing my
meeting is your yoga that's like you
understand that's what makes me happy
that's what makes me relaxed I get
relaxed when I'm working like like like
I'm sorry I'm not wired like you
you